quand une maladie infectieuse frappe une
population animale etc un pathogène se
répand comme une traînée de poudre
on parle alors d'une épizootie c'est
l'équivalent d'une épidémie chez
l'humain l'une des plus importantes
épizooties à avoir frappé les élevages
c'est la fièvre aphteuse cette maladie
s'attaque surtout aux ports aux bovins
aux moutons et aux chèvres elles causent
une forte fièvre et le développement de
boutons qu'on appelle des aphtes le
virus de la fièvre aphteuse est
hautement contagieux il se propage dans
l'air sur plusieurs kilomètres la fièvre
aphteuse n'a pas frappé le canada depuis
50 ans mais elle tient toujours les
vétérinaires du monde entier sur un pied
d'alert car il surgit régulièrement de
nouveaux foyers d'épidémie les volailles
peuvent elles aussi être frappé par des
épizooties les virus à l'origine de la
grippe aviaire dans les élevages de
poulets ou de dindons en sont de bons
exemples
les oiseaux sauvages constituent des
réservoirs naturels des virus de la
grippe aviaire
ce sont eux qui bien souvent transmettre
les virus de l'influenza aux oiseaux
d'élevage
certains virus de la grippe aviaire
comme le h5n1 ont aussi la capacité
d'infecter les humains car de tels virus
franchissent la barrière des espèces
on parle alors d'une zoonose